(pensive music)
Dr. Beste is here
to talk about something important,
which is well-child care.
And she is an expert on adolescent care
'cause she has emerging adults now in her family.
I have emerging adults now.
Okay, take it over Jan. Thank you.
For those of you who don't know,
after adolescence, they are now emerging adults.
Those 18 to 26 year olds, so to speak.
Okay, so we're gonna talk about kids.
I still have nothing to disclose.
Here are our learning objectives, so we're gonna get going.
So the well-child visit,
what do we do at the well-child visit?
If you ask parents, they're going to say,
"Well, they're there for shots."
Well, there's obviously a lot more than just shots.
You're doing history.
You're doing growth and development.
You're doing your physical.
You're doing all kinds of health screenings.
And then you also are doing vaccines,
as well as advising the parents as to what to expect next.
So let's start with our first question.
You are performing a developmental examination
on an 18-month-old boy.
Which of the following would be abnormal for this age group?
That he only scribbles when given a crayon?
That he can drink from a cup?
That he just babbles and imitates sounds?
Or that he can stack two blocks?
All right. Yes, good!
Most of you realize that a child who's only babbling
and imitating sounds an 18 month old,
that is not normal.
So I'm not gonna go through all of these in detail,
but I do encourage you to review them.
Mostly you really wanna focus on the verbal
and gross motor developments.
Those seem to be the ones that come up pretty frequently
on the boards.
Mostly remembering that two months of age
is when they start smiling and start vocalizing,
which is what saves their lives, by the way,
'cause that's when colic also happens.
By the time they're six months,
they should be able to sit up and not have any head lag.
By nine months,
they should be able to sit completely without support.
They can start standing and cruising.
And this is when they start doing the dada, mama.
By one year of age, they should start to walk,
at least walk with help, standing alone.
They start babbling, so this is that babbling.
They should respond to no.
Doesn't mean that they stopped doing,
but they should at least be like, "Mom just said no."
So at 18 months, they can walk backwards.
They can speak three to six words.
This is a good milestone to know.
They can stack those two blocks
and understand simple commands by two years of age.
As toddlers, they can speak 50 words,
put two words together, and understand a two-part command.
That's a good one to remember.
They should know six body parts, stack four blocks.
They take off their clothes,
frequently, in inappropriate settings.
By three years of age,
they can understand what hungry and tired is.
They can name four pictures.
They can pedal a tricycle.
And they ask, "Why?"
So two years of age, it's know why.
One of the great things,
both my husband and I are doctors,
about us both being doctors is when our kids asked
why we gave them really long,
lengthy scientific explanations.
So that phase didn't last very long in our house.
So by four years, they become a cute little kid.
They're getting ready to go to kindergarten,
so they should be able to name four colors,
know their first and last name.
They can go up and down stairs, alternating feet.
They can draw a circle.
They're super fun at that age.
Okay, so some of the things
that are recommended in this age group.
So autism spectrum disorder screening is recommended
by the American Academy of Pediatrics.
It is an I recommendation by USPSTF.
Don't panic.
I have a nice little chart
where the AAP differs from the USPSTF.
You'll never be asked, you know, one of those things.
But just for your own interest,
which ones are recommended by which?
So autism, whoa, look at this:
More prevalent in siblings of autistic children.
Early interventions have been shown to improve outcomes.
So let's move on to USPSTF recommendations.
There are no A recommendations in this age group.
Ooh, but there's a whole bunch of B recommendations.
So B recommendations I would pay attention to:
The first couple are about fluoride.
So oral fluoride,
if the fluoride is low in their water supply,
remembering that even if they have city water
or well water with fluoride,
they may not be drinking it.
I've been impressed with the number of families
that only drink bottled water without fluoride.
So ask about that.
So we want oral fluoride supplementation.
Put fluoride application on their teeth.
Vision screening for all children once
between the ages of three to five
to detect amblyopia.
Obesity screening.
We'll talk about that a little bit more.
And skin cancer prevention counseling.
I live at the beach in North Carolina.
I fight on this one all the time.
Put some sunscreen on your kids.
Okay, this may be new for some of you
if you haven't taken care of kids for a while.
One of the new USPSTF recommendations is to screen the moms
for maternal depression at the 1, 2, 4,
and 6 month well-child visits.
Most of you are using PHQ-9s in your office.
You can use that.
If you want to,
you can use the Edinburgh Postnatal Depression Scale,
but you should be doing that in some states.
In North Carolina, we actually get paid for it.
Dental caries.
So we talked about fluoride.
Dental caries are the most common chronic disease
of young children.
So when parents ask, you should brush their teeth
with fluoride toothpaste twice a day,
rice-sized amount until they're at age two,
then a pea-sized amount.
I think that's helpful for parents to understand
how much to put on.
Floss as soon as the teeth are touching.
They should have a dentist by age three.
Here's a nice little handy-dandy chart.
Again, you can use Dr. Google to find this chart
from the American Academy of Pediatric Dentistry
if you need to.
Okay, somebody asked
at the last talk about pediatric screening for eye vision.
So here are your recommendations
for referring if their visual acuity
is less than 20/40 by three or 20/30 by age five:
Anytime you have asymmetry.
Or if they have quotes, "a lazy eye,"
strabismus at 3 to 6 months.
And any abnormal red reflex.
So this is why amblyopia due to strabismus,
so that lazy eye,
so if you're looking at their eye
and one eye is drifting when you do the cover on cover test,
it's a leading cause of monocular vision loss in children.
So the recommendation
is that you should do the official screening at age four.
It's where you have 'em,
you know, stand and look at the vision chart
and try to tell you what all those pictures are.
Instrument-based is the, you know, looking in their eyes
with your ophthalmoscope,
doing the cover on cover time,
making sure that the eyes stay straight.
Obesity screening.
This is I think my favorite screening recommendation.
They say you should screen for obesity
in children and adolescents greater than six years of age.
And you should offer/refer them
to comprehensive, intensive behavioral interventions
greater than 25 hours of face-to-face, family-based,
multi-component treatment over 3 to 12 months
to promote improvements in weight.
I don't know about you, but I have no access to that.
So just be aware that is the recommendation.
That's because almost 20% of children
and adolescents are obese,
and a third of children in this country are overweight.
And that number stabilized a little bit lately.
Why do we care about obesity in children?
There's mental health issues, asthma,
obstructive sleep apnea has worsened,
they have orthopedic problems,
and of course all the cardiovascular metabolic
things that we think about.
And also, particularly in this age group,
they really have a lot of weight-based victimization.
Not to say that adults don't,
but it's really cruel in this age group.
And obesity in childhood and adolescents
may continue into adulthood.
And then you have
all of the associated cardiovascular issues
that we know about.
This is kind of just a fun little thing.
If a child drinks more than five cans of soda a day
or is active less than one hour a day,
their risk increases.
So that's kind of a nice easy thing you can ask.
Don't drink five cans of soda a day.
And of course, like everything else,
significant racial and ethnic disparities exist
with our Hispanic children having the highest rates
followed closely by our non-Hispanic Black children.
There are no D recommendations in this age group.
Okay, so I recommendations.
You do not need to know all of the I recommendations.
There are a couple of them
that differ from the American Academy of Pediatrics,
and I will go through those.
I put 'em in orange, but I also made this cool little chart.
So if you notice that the American Academy of Pediatrics
recommends that you screen for iron deficiency anemia,
whereas USPSTF makes out an I recommendation,
the AAP recommends the screening for lipids.
This does come up on the board,
so I would make sure that you pay attention
to the AAP recommendation.
Risk-based screening at 2, 4, and 6 years,
but universal screening in the school age years 9 to 11,
and 17 to 21.
Screening for hypertension.
And use of a brief formal screening instrument
to detect speech language delay up to age five,
recommended by the AAP, a I recommendation by USPSTF.
Briefly, just about anemia affects
about 50% of children worldwide.
By far, in the United States,
the most common cause is iron deficiency.
Remember what I said earlier
about supplementing your kids with iron
in that first year of life.
And because it's so common in this country,
the recommendation is if you detect anemia,
put them on some iron, recheck it in a month.
If it goes up by one gram,
it's probably iron deficiency anemia.
If it doesn't, first of all,
make sure the parents gave it to them.
I would say the highest percentage of patients
that don't get better because the parent's like,
"Eh, I really didn't think it was that important."
So just make sure the parents gave it to 'em.
If not, then you need to look at other causes.
And obviously, if you're starting to look
in normocytic or macrocytic anemia,
you gotta go through a much more intense evaluation.
Okay, next question.
So you have a mother who brings her 9-month-old daughter in
for her routine visit.
So which of the following
should be addressed at a nine-month well-child visit?
Would you talk about starting table food?
About sleeping on her back?
Would you recommend a hearing test
or would you say it's time to talk about toilet training?
Good.
Three quarters of you knew that starting table food
is what you talk about at nine months.
So remember, we talked a few minutes ago
about developmental issues with children?
When you're talking about anticipatory guidance to parents,
what you're basically is warning them about what is to come.
So you're thinking about what do you need to do
to keep the environment safe?
Because this is what they're going to do next.
So for example, in those first few weeks,
you're talking about making sure they're in a car seat,
putting 'em to back to sleep, don't smoke around them.
A lot of the things that you know seem to be logical to us.
But by four months, you're starting to talk about,
okay, coming up soon, we're gonna be introducing solid food.
So start thinking about that.
By six months, you're like,
okay, they're gonna start crawling
and probably gonna start walking.
Start baby proofing the house.
Don't use walkers.
By nine months, now they're starting to become more mobile,
so you start thinking about what kind of dangers are there
around the house.
You start talking about keeping the doors
to the bathroom latched
so that they can't fall in and drown.
By 12 months, again, they're starting to get mobile,
so you're childproofing the house.
You may talk to mom about weaning
if she's interested in weaning.
At 12 months, you're talking about
they should be on table foods at this point.
And again, I'm not gonna read through all of these,
but you can see the things
that you're discussing with the parents have to do
with what the child
is going to be doing next developmentally.
Okay, discipline, we get asked a lot about discipline.
So the evidence actually shows
that positive reinforcement to increase appropriate behavior
is much more effective than anything else.
So catch them being good.
Most low level bad behavior, you just kind of ignore it.
You just don't pay a lot of attention to it.
You can't do the timeouts for the more problematic behavior.
For older kids,
you can actually make little sticker charts,
like, "Every time you and your brother play nicely together,
we'll put a sticker on the chart."
And kids like putting stickers on charts.
And parents should be cautioned
that punishment doesn't really work that well.
It suppresses the behavior right at the time,
but kids don't have the the ability to say,
"Huh, I'm two years old
and I whacked my brother in the head with a Lego
and I should not to do that again
because mom came and hit me upside the head with it."
They can't put that all together.
And also, speaking of which, we don't recommend spanking,
mostly because it's actually associated
with increased aggression,
negative parent-child relationships.
And again, kids, they cannot put their effects
and actions together,
and you just shouldn't do it.
Okay, screen time.
This was really fun counseling during the pandemic.
I'm sure all of you got to say,
"Let's talk about limiting screen time during the pandemic."
So the official American Academy of Pediatric
recommendations are less than 18 months,
no screen time except for video chatting.
Now we all know what that is.
That's code for the grandparents
wanna see the grandchild, right?
So there is no video chatting at 18 months,
but that kind of things.
By 18 to 24 months, high-quality programming,
parents should watch it with their children.
Two to five years,
you should limit screen use to one hour a day
of high-quality programming.
Again, parents should view it with their children.
And over the age of six,
you should have some limits on your media time.
Toilet training.
When should a child be ready to toilet train?
Usually it's about ages two to three.
It's when they're interested.
They can follow that two-step command,
and they can put their clothes up and down,
and they wanna do what the parents are doing.
All right, next question.
At a well-child check, a five-year-old boy is noted
to have some bedwetting occasionally.
So you advise the parents that:
This problem indicates abuse or emotional problems.
This problem is rare in the absence of a family history.
This problem rarely resolves spontaneously.
Or this occurs in 20 to 25% of boys at this age,
being the age of five.
Okay, 95% of you though picked
that 20, 25% of boys have enuresis.
So this is bedwetting after the age of five.
It is higher if the parent had a history of enuresis.
It's higher in boys than the girls.
It usually goes away on its own.
And the treatment is either alarms.
You can use desmopressin for occasional use.
Encopresis, which is, you know, the fecal leaking,
usually is around constipation.
So you treat the constipation.
This is where the sticker charts often help out
to, you know, have 'em go to the bathroom after dinner
and get a sticker.
Okay, constipation.
Most common cause of constipation is functional,
which means they just get too busy to go to the bathroom.
So daily use of polyethylene glycol is more effective
than any of these other laxatives out there.
There's really no adverse effects noted.
Here is the dose.
We talked about fiber can be used on maintenance.
Look at how long it takes for this to work.
Six to 12 months.
So I know most of you have had the parent
who used it for two weeks and came back and said,
"Well, now he's constipated again."
I'm like, "Yep, you're gonna have to do this
for probably six months to sort of retrain the bowel
to work the way it should."
Okay, sleep.
I want you to look at how many hours of sleep
are needed per day for kids.
What?
Way more than we would think it is,
especially those teenagers.
I don't know if any of you know any teenagers
who sleep 8 to 10 hours a night.
Certainly not my kids when they were teenagers,
despite my best efforts.
Other sleep disorders, you can have insomnia.
It's almost always behavioral.
Obstructive sleep apnea,
especially with your obese children.
And parasomnias.
That's your night terrors, sleepwalking, nightmares.
All right, next question.
Ooh, this is an important one.
What's the most appropriate automobile seating
for a 7-year-old who is 50 inches tall?
Rear seat, using lap and shoulder belt alone.
Rear seat in a belt-positioning booster seat
with a lap and shoulder belt.
Rear seat in a forward-facing child seat
with a five-point harness.
Or center of rear seat in a booster seat
with lap belt alone.
Ooh, that's a lot of words.
All right, excellent.
Rear seat and a belt-positioning booster seat
with a lap and shoulder belt.
Okay, very quickly.
Infant toddlers:
rear seat, rear-facing car seat
until they're about the age of two.
Rear seat, forward-facing car seat,
this is your preschoolers
until the maximum weight or height for that seat.
Then school-aged kids are still in the rear,
belt-positioning booster seat,
and they don't get to move into the front seat
until they're 13.
Okay, I think this is probably the most helpful thing.
If you look at the pictures,
you can see the infant seat backwards-facing till age two.
Preschoolers, facing-forward, but in the harness.
Booster seat up until they outgrow the booster seat.
I just tell my parents that seatbelt,
when they get outta the booster seat,
that seatbelt has to cross their chest
and their lap just like it would for an adult.
It doesn't go across their neck.
It doesn't go over their face or behind their head.
It has to go across their chest.
All right, I just put this in here for you to study.
I'm not gonna go over all of this.
This is the vaccine schedule.
I am gonna talk about one though
that I think is very important.
Oh, the monoclonal antibody for RSV
that came out this past year.
It was approved in summer.
Nirsevimab, it's given one IM injection protection
for about five months.
It's recommended for all infants
who are younger than eight months when RSV season starts,
which over the past few years was, ah, who's guess?
But seems like we're moving back to a normal RSV season.
If the mom got the RSV vaccine,
then the child doesn't necessarily need it,
which I'm not sure if David's gonna talk to you about that
with the pregnancy talk.
Children at severe risk also should get it
during their second season.
Now that is to say, if you could actually get it.
Our office could never actually get it.
Okay, we're gonna talk about healthcare in adolescence.
So I do wanna take a minute
to talk about vaccines in adolescence.
Some of these have changed.
So the 11 to 12,
so these are the sixth grade shots.
We've always talked about the kindergarten shots.
These are the sixth grade shots.
And you can see some meningococcal, Tdap, influenza, HPV,
this is a great board question.
If they get their HPV vaccines before the age of 15,
you only need two.
They wait till after 15, three.
I have convinced many a child to get their vaccine earlier
because I said, "Now you don't want three shots, do you?"
They go, "Oh no, get it done today."
And of course, COVID-19.
And then the upper high school shots,
their second meningococcal.
Or you can either do the separate MCV4
and the meningitis type B.
Or you can use the new combined vaccine.
And of course your flu and COVID.
Okay, there are some A recommendations in this group.
Folic acid supplementation.
Folic acid for all women
from their very first period to the very last period.
HIV screening for adolescents
by the time they're 15 or younger,
if they're at increased risk.
Pre-exposure prophylaxis for those at risk of HIV.
And syphilis screening for those at risk.
B recommendations, you'll notice a lot
of the recommendations in this age group is around sex.
So chlamydia/gonorrhea screening
in sexually active females less than 25.
Counseling about STIs.
Then you have screening for depressive disorder and anxiety.
You notice that the anxiety starts at age eight.
Depression starts at age 12.
Obesity screening.
We already talked about counseling,
about minimizing UV exposure.
We already talked about intimate partner violence screening
for females of childbearing age.
Interventions to prevent initiation of tobacco.
And hepatitis B screening if at high risk.
Then there's a few Ds.
Remember, D is don't do these.
Don't do testicular cancer screening
for asymptomatic adolescents.
You don't do pap smears for screening under the age of 21.
And you don't screen for herpes and asymptomatic adolescents
or for anyone for that matter.
Okay, bunch of I recommendations.
Not gonna go through these again.
We talked already about the screening for lipid disorders.
The American Academy of Pediatrics does recommend that
between the ages of eight and 11 and then 17 to 21.
Bullying.
These numbers are kind of sobering.
20% of all adolescents are bullied on school property.
Quite a significant number of them report cyber bullying.
Remember, back in the day when I was in school,
the only way you got bullied
is if the bully was face to face.
Now, online, you can be bullied
in front of everyone in your school.
Over 50% of our LGBTQ adolescents report being bullied.
And this is important
'cause adolescents who are bullied are more likely
to carry a weapon to school
and experience depression, anxiety,
suicidal thoughts, and self harm.
Okay, blood pressure, thank goodness.
A few years ago,
the guidelines for blood pressure change.
So if you look at those adolescent guidelines,
they look remarkably similar to our adult guidelines.
Thank you.
Under the age of 13,
it's still the age and height and gender.
So there's tables that you can look at.
And you can see the definitions based on the percentile
based on their age.
Hypertension.
It used to be, back when I was a resident,
the top causes of hypertension
were things that you were born with.
Primary hypertension is now the number one cause
of hypertension in this age group.
You have to confirm it on three occasions.
For all children who you diagnose with hypertension,
you can see the recommended testing, upper and lower,
upper arm and leg blood pressure measurements.
UA and BMP. Lipids.
Drug screening. Yes.
And ambulatory blood pressure monitoring
is actually recommended for kids
that you diagnosed with hypertension.
If you have obese children,
think about a thyroid, A1C, LFTs.
Maybe a sleep study.
We all know obstructive sleep apnea in adults
causes hypertension,
also causes it in kids.
If they're young, so if they're under the age of six,
now you're thinking maybe this is a congenital thing.
So you're gonna think about your renal ultrasound
and you know, considering causes
that they might have been born with.
And if you're thinking about treatment,
you wanna get an echocardiogram.
What do you treat them with?
So I want you to notice this is a difference from adults.
With adults, we do the therapeutic lifestyle changes,
come on back in a few months, see how things are going.
Here, it's two to three weeks.
Stage one with end-organ damage or they persist.
Or they have stage two, you start them on medication.
And you'll notice, these all look very familiar, right?
It's very similar to what you do with your adults.
Please remember, just like you do
with any of your women of childbearing age,
if you're gonna put them on an Ace or an ARB,
you need to talk about contraception.
And you wanna get them back to a normal blood pressure.
Okay, unintentional death in this age group.
The number one,
I had to change this slide about two years ago.
Number one cause of unintentional death in the United States
ages 1 to 18 is firearms.
Under the age of 1, it's suffocation.
1 to 5, it's drowning.
And then adolescents, it's firearms.
Of these firearms, 97% are intentional,
two thirds of are homicides,
one third are suicides,
followed by motor vehicle accidents,
poisoning, mostly opioid overdoses,
and then suffocation, 98% of which are suicide.
This data is from the CDC.
If anybody wants to go and check me on this,
I did confirm this as of November.
Tanner staging.
Just something to review when you have a few minutes.
This is for, again, anticipatory guidance
to warn the parents about what is coming.
Boys and girls.
Next question:
Which of the following is true
of bulimia nervosa in adolescent females?
Is it more prevalent than anorexia nervosa?
Is it a restriction of food intake leading to weight loss?
Is it characterized by low body mass index?
Or is it most common in white, upper middle class females?
So this is bulimia nervosa.
All right, we got a little bit
of a learning opportunity here.
So let's talk about bulimia.
So I want to look at this prevalence:
1 to 19%, what does that tell you?
We're not doing a good job of diagnosing it, are we?
But it is actually much more common
than most of us would believe.
So this is recurrent episodes of binge eating
with recurrent inappropriate compensatory behavior.
So that compensatory behavior
can be chewing down a bunch of laxatives.
It can be going to throw up.
I just ate, you know, four boxes of girl scout cookies.
Now I gotta get rid of it somehow.
Binge eating and compensatory behaviors occur
at least once a week for three months.
So it's a recurrent thing, not just a one time thing.
And I think this is what is really important.
Their self-evaluation is influenced
by body shape and weight.
Can you think of why our adolescents
might have a big problem with this?
If you don't, I'm gonna tell you.
It's called Instagram and TikTok and YouTube.
Social media has had a huge influence on this.
So people look at that and say,
"My body doesn't look like that."
And so there's an awful lot of unhealthy behaviors
to try to address that.
These are the things we all learned about in medical school.
You know, the dental enamel erosions from throwing up,
the edema.
I don't know that you necessarily see this.
So mostly you just need to ask
how do you feel about your body?
And are you ever trying to do something
to make yourself look differently than you are right now?
So anorexia is different.
This is a much lower prevalence.
This is your 90% white, upper middle class,
the high-risk sports.
So you think about your dancers,
your swimmers, your cheerleaders.
In boys, you think about your wrestlers,
the people who are trying to make weight very quickly.
So this is usually a restriction of food intake.
So they lose weight or they don't gain weight.
They have an intense fear of gaining weight.
They have a very distorted body image as well.
So you'll have a girl
who's, you know, got a BMI of 15
who's like, "Oh, look at all this fat under my arms."
You know, it's a little bit of loose skin.
And you can have a binging/purging type.
The difference is these people usually
have a very low body weight.
So the treatment for this: psychotherapy,
really, really, really intense psychotherapy.
This is not an easy disease to treat.
And it is a recurring and relapsing disease.
So I have some adult women who had this,
were diagnosed as adolescents
and they still go through periods of this.
And these are all your clinical signs
and symptoms that we were taught in medical school.
Your amenorrhea.
They can have bradycardia.
They can have very low body temperature.
And they can end up with osteoporosis at a young age.
Okay, a couple quick things.
Some of the frequent flyers you'll see:
We talked about blood pressure.
Make sure you know the general principles
of the blood pressure in children.
Development.
Please look at that chart.
Just go through it
and try to remember what happens at each age.
Car seats.
That cool little chart that I showed you
with the pictures,
just memorize that.
You will need to know that.
Look at the USPSTF recommendations.
Know where it varies
from The American Academy of Pediatrics.
I have found that in general,
they follow the American Academy
of Pediatrics recommendations when they ask you questions.
The causes death in different age groups
and review the vaccine schedules.
All right, and there are the answers in case you missed it.
Thank you.
(pensive music)